ce jour là l'hélicoptère s'attaquer à la
falaise
pour désherber
l'île de lento n'hésite pas à employer
les grands moyens
cet hélicoptère a fait un long voyage
il est venu du continent de sydney li
vainement est d'importance pour les
rangers de lille une dizaine d'employés
chargés de veiller en permanence sur
l'environnement là tout le monde
installe un énorme réservoir à un
herbicide pour un nouveau tour dans les
airs l'autre solution c'est d'envoyer
des gens suspendus à des cordes au
milieu des falaises avec des
vaporisateurs et nous on peut pulvériser
d'en haut et avancer très vite donc
c'est moins cher et c'est beaucoup moins
dangereux
l'hélicoptère comme outils de jardinage
pour franck bauer le chef des rangers
c'est une occasion unique de combattre
l'ennemi le bitoux
cette mauvaise herbe a envahi l'île il
faut la supprimer coûte que coûte
contrôler le bitoux par aspersion avec
l'hélicoptère tous les deux à quatre ans
on a éliminé 500 buisson en quatre
années
on espère qu'on va quasiment les
éradiquer ironie du sort la mauvaise
herbe a été introduite à l'origine pour
empêcher l'érosion côtière
nous sommes 1 700 km au large de sydney
dans l'océan pacifique
cet îlot profil volcanique salon sur 11
km
la plupart des 300 habitants descendent
des premiers colons britanniques
installé en 1834
d'autres sont venus pour travailler dans
l'administration ou le tourisme
les ne cherchez pas de village alors au
nid de place principale
vous trouverez en revanche quelques
maisons cacher derrière la végétation
ian et dean habitent tous les deux sur
l'île il ya une faute on a débarqué ici
il y à 20 environ
depuis il a écrit des livres sur les
oiseaux les poissons les coraux les
arbres enfin peu surtout pourvu que ça
parle de l'ordre au et de nature
aujourd'hui comptage des naissances chez
les fous masqués
le premier poussan a pris toute la
nourriture et n'y a que lui qui a
survécu
la plupart de ces oiseaux en 2e mais un
seul survie ici les oiseaux de mer
trouve à se nourrir ils ont besoin de se
poser à terre pour se reproduire
c'est pourquoi ils viennent à l'ordre il
n'y a pas de prédateurs originaire de
l'île
ils sont complètement en sécurité ici on
a démontré que c'est possible il vous
pouvez avoir un environnement naturel
sain et une communauté humaine
florissante mais pour arriver à cet
équilibre
il faut beaucoup de discussions et
d'organisation et vous devez avoir des
règles et des lois pour protéger et
s'assurer que l'équilibré est maintenu
donc ce n'est pas facile du tout mais
c'est possible
l' équilibre entre les hommes et la
nature la grande question allan poe et
voilà qu'au détour du chemin on tombe
sur une douzaine une espèce de kiwi
locale très rare dans les années 70 on
pense qu'il nous restait plus que 20
maximum 30
et maintenant il y en a trois sont tout
autour du livre et ceci grâce à un
programme de sauvetage au début des
années 80 qui a consisté à se
débarrasser complètement des chats des
cochons et à contrôler les chiens ils
ont pu se reproduire à nouveau sur l'île
le projet wooden a été le plus réussi de
tous les projets de réimplantation
d'oiseaux au monde depuis la roue dance
est tellement bien accoutumée qu'elle
picore jusque dans les bureaux de
l'administration
mais le règlement est resté les chats
les cochons ainsi que les chèvres sont
absolument interdit pour ne pas déranger
les oiseaux
d'autres lois viennent encadrer la vie
sur l'île la vitesse est limitée à 25 km
heure il n'y a pas de téléphone portable
ni de visites des gros bateaux de
croisière
toutes ces règles sont votées par le
conseil de lille ce sont les habitants
eux-mêmes qui choisissent cette vie bon
il accepte tout de même un peu de
touristes on avait entendu dire que le
nombre de visiteurs était limité c'est
un endroit pas polluer du tout et c'est
un genre de paradis on peut séjourner
alors on l'a choisi je trouve ça bien
d'avoir une circulation l'an pas
beaucoup de voitures et beaucoup de gens
qui marchent qui font du vélo ou qui
roulent en voitures électriques
oui c'est bien en plus c'est très propre
et très beau à voir
et certains de ces touristes volts au
secours des plantes de l'auto
car elles sont en danger une petite
armée de débroussailleurs bénévoles est
venu de toute l'australie sous les
ordres de monsieur nature ian burton
utilise de l'herbicide on n'utilise pas
de vaporisateurs parce qu'évidemment
s'attaquerait aussi les planques locale
donc juste un peu d'herbicides une
goutte sur la tige qu'on a coupé et
c'est pas ici l'ennemi s'appelle la
sparagus une plante amenés un jour d'un
fortune par un jardinier amateur il faut
l'empoisonner racines par racine
et dire qu'ils font cela pendant leurs
vacances
on est tous bénévoles et payent pour
notre voyage on paye pour notre séjour
commun et c'est pour le bien de lille
les petits centres comme celui là sont
étouffés par la sparagus ils n'ont pas
pu pousser et peuvent même mourir
maintenant celui ci a été libéré et
celui là aussi le soleil peut les
atteindre et ils peuvent devenir très
grand
les esprits chagrins vont dire encore un
coup de l'homme ce malfaisant
mais il semblerait que cet oiseau noir
soit aussi dans le coup le karaoké de
l'ordre comme est responsable de la
dissémination de la sparagus parce que
la mangent les fruits et ensuite les
disperse partout dans la forêt riche et
plein de petits des plantes poussent
partout à se demander si ce n'est pas le
cas raconte lui-même qu'il faudrait
éradiquer
ah non j'oubliais un détail il est du
coin lui
un parc marin a été créé il ya cinq ans
autour de l'île sa liane travail pour se
parquer ce matin elle se met à l'eau
avec taz qui lui tient un club de
plongée tous deux unissent leurs efforts
pour surveiller le lagon aujourd'hui il
plonge pour mesurer les changements dans
la faune et la flore
apparemment tout va pour le mieux il y
aurait même des petits nouveaux
mannix il ya un étonnant mélange
d'écosystèmes ici qui rend le parc marin
de leur unique une abondance de poissons
différents types de coraux un mélange de
maquereaux alliant
mais fait la singularité vient du
mélange d'eau tropicales et tempérées
le courant est australien amène des eaux
chaudes et des poissons tropicaux est un
courant fort apporte des espèces habitué
à vivre en eaux plus froides
on découvre encore de nouvelles espèces
ce qui est très excitant
il y à de nombreuses espèces qu'on ne
trouve que dans ces eaux là
on
le parc marin a imposé des sanctuaires
des bout d'océan où il est interdit de
pêcher ou de tenir quoi que ce soit
taz a connu des vieux pêcheur qui
renâclait devant ces nouvelles règles
drastiques les zones sanctuaires sont
maintenant acceptées par les locaux ils
se rendent compte que l'écosystème marin
est important pour leur gagne pain
s'il ya des restrictions c'est aussi
dans leur intérêt
il réalise qu'à long terme c'est
bénéfique doc au début ça a été dur et
maintenant tout le monde l'acceptent
chaque jour un avion arrive de sydney au
brisbane
aujourd'hui lille attend un de ses
bienfaiteurs
c'est pourtant la première fois qu'il va
mettre le pied sur l'île avec sa femme
française tout ce que vous voyez sur la
droite
c'est le lagon protégés par des récifs
mike rooney voulait voir cet archipel
tant vantée pour lequel il a fait un
geste rare c'est vraiment très beau je
dois vous dire que je suis très heureux
d'avoir cédé nos droits au parc national
ils peuvent préserver l'endroit mais je
dois dire aussi que je ne suis pas un
écologiste
je veux juste préserver les choses
s'étaient apaisées
mike rooney a longtemps dirigé une
grande société et pendant des années ces
bateaux en pêcher des poissons de grands
fonds autour de l'archipel
et puis un jour il a décidé de faire don
de ses droits de pêche au parc marin
pour que jamais plus des navires
industriels ne vienne mettre en danger
les espèces locales
c'est très inhabituel la politique de
notre entreprise était de faire
attention très sérieusement à la
préservation des ressources regarder la
possibilité de pêcher sans abîmer cette
ressource et nous avons une philosophie
qui dit vous ne pouvez pas prendre tout
le temps il faut aussi savoir donner de
temps en temps
énergie solaire utilisation maximale de
l'eau de pluie une telle il se doit bien
évidemment d'être irréprochable et parmi
les trois magasins du centre ville
il en est à 100 marques commerciales
apparent c'est bien y a pas besoin
d'emballage pour acheter ça j'amène mon
propre sac
j'amène les peaux je mets mes chocolats
dedans doit réutiliser et recycler comme
ça on produit pas de tout changer
résultat zéro déchet ou presque et les
quelques déchets qui restent sont
recyclés à 90%
et oui c'est possible il suffit d'une
station de traitement adapté et de la
bonne volonté des habitants
tous les déchets organiques e serviront
à faire du compost pour l'agriculture
locale et les objets usés dont on veut
se séparer ne finissent jamais à la
poubelle c'est comme il le racontait
n'importe qui peut laisser ici quelque
chose dont il n'a plus besoin de
raconter encore étudier et si quelqu'un
veut l'emporter il le fait on doit être
conscient des déchets qu'on produit
c'est un coup énorme pour lui ces
déchets sur maintenant
les sens taz le plongeur est originaire
de l'ordre au sa copine lorraine vient
de melbourne simple locataire pour
l'instant leurs rêves et d'emménager
dans leur propre maison mais pas 6 1 car
sur l'île les règlements décide aussi du
nombre de maisons à bâtir pour le moment
on attend le tirage au sort en fait
votre nom et placés dans une urne et
reste à espérer qu'il va sortir et du
coup on peut construire
combien de maisons on va avoir le droit
de construire dans les prochaines années
c'est seulement onze maisons dans les 20
prochaines années
en fait ils mettent votre nom dans un
chapeau avec un peu de chance vous
tenons pas être retiré et on aura
l'autorisation de construire
était plus con c'est difficile
d'attendre mais nous faut voir le bon
côté
comme ça au moins l'ordre restera pur
pas construite a vendu au commerce
la pyramide de bol un éperon rocheux
planté dans l'océan à 20 km de l'île
principale
ici il y a quelques années une
expédition à trouver par hasard un
animal très rare que l'on croyait
disparu à jamais
aujourd'hui de ranger son déposer
quelques heures sur cet îlot interdit au
public pour surveiller cette étrange
bestiole
bon nous on est les grimper tout seul
sur ce pic vertigineux
hank bauer va nous présenter cet animal
tranquillement à terre car il en garde
quelques-uns précieusement enfermé dans
une cabane tient les voilà ce sont des
phasmes ou du moins une espèce de
phasmes gigantesque des insectes pouvant
atteindre 20 cm de long c'est le phasme
de l'ordre au connu aussi sous le nom de
omar terrestre
il y en avait combien il y en avait des
milliers dans le temps sur l'île de leur
duo va sont arrivés et les ont tous
mangé on sait qu'ils avaient disparu à
jamais les miraculés
ils se sont reproduits en captivité au
zoo de melbourne et il en existe
aujourd'hui plus de 400 dont une
quinzaine ici à l'abri de leurs ennemis
mortels
et maintenant l'idée serait tout
bonnement de réintroduire le phasme sur
leur dos
mais il y aller' à des milliers de rats
qui gambadent partout la nuit et qu'on
ne voit jamais johnny le ranger est
chargé de vérifier les quelques pièges
empoisonné déjà installés
esternay c'est un problème très sensible
pour lille mais moi personnellement je
pense qu'il y a un problème se
débarrasser des rats serait une bonne
chose pour l'heure où l'homme a
introduit les rongeurs au paradis les
rats ont profité d'un naufrage pour
débarquer ici en 1918
ils se sont multipliés en quelques mois
et ils ont rapidement éliminé plusieurs
espèces d'oiseaux ou d'insectes dont le
fassent leurs friandises préférées
la solution est donc toute trouvée pour
faire revenir le phasme il faut tuer les
rats les souris
le programme d'éradication des rats est
un peu controversé
c'est un concept qui vient de l'étranger
on jette du poison par hélicoptère tout
autour de l'île
en revanche près des habitations on va
le mettre à la main certains membres de
la communauté sont un peu inquiets on
doit passer par tout un processus de
consultation
il faut dire que ce projet semble irréel
essayez d'imaginer toute l'île doit être
empoisonné pendant plus de trois mois
pour cela il faudra notamment enfermé
tout le bétail et les chiens et surtout
attraper le plus possible d'oiseaux
sauvages pour les mettre à l'abri
m
les oiseaux sauvages dans des cages
pendant 100 jours
tout cela pour réimplanter un insecte
effrayant
pour certains habitants s'en est trop
pixie par exemple qui dirige un hôtel
avec son mari comme la majeure partie de
la population elle vit du tourisme
ça serait super d'en être débarrassé
mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils vont le
faire de la bonne façon je n'arrive pas
à croire qu'ils vont attraper les
oiseaux les wooden les carabes onglet
passereaux enfermer les vaches et que
va-t-il se passer pour l'industrie du
tourisme pendant qu'ils feront ça est ce
que les gens vont vouloir venir sur une
île massivement recouverte de ce sale
poison est ce que le vol régulier va
être maintenue je n'en sais rien qu'est
ce qui va se passer comment je vais
gagner ma vie je sais pas attendons pour
voir
ce n'est pas la première fois que l'on
tente d'éradiquer les rats allant de
haut
dans les années 20 les habitants ont
fait venir un gros rapaces méthodes
naturelles mais on ne peut pas dire que
ce fut une grande réussite
même en cas qui dirige le nouveau
programme se méfie un peu des
conséquences voudrait introduire la
petite chouette qui a disparu qu'on le
conseil de lille a fait venir la grande
chouette qu'ils devaient contrôler
l'erreur pour réintroduire la petite
chouette on doit d'abord contrôler les
rats et tué la grosse chouette c'est
très compliqué dans l'écologie du nil si
tu commences à tirer sur un fil de
l'écosystème toute la pelote se défait
le programme d'éradication des rats sera
à l'étude jusqu'en 2011
après la population sera appelée à voter
c'est pour tuer les champignons peuvent
s'attaquer à la végétation de lille est
juste une précaution les gens ont pu les
ramener de sydney ou d'ailleurs
alors trouvé
fin de ses jours les débroussailleurs
ont droit à une récompense
découvrir les beautés de l'île avec ian
burton admirer des coraux très rare
vivant dans des rochers immergé à marée
haute
c'est un bel exemple pour le reste du
monde les gens viennent ici et voit que
c'est un endroit dont l'environnement
est vraiment bien protégé
les débroussailleurs bénévoles sont déjà
des convaincus ils vont même parfois
plus loin que le naturaliste
mais je pense que la terre est faite
pour tous les animaux et des plantes
wilson juste une toute petite partie de
cela elle doit s'en souvenir et arrêter
de traiter la terre comme notre terrain
de jeu point de 300
certains penseront que tout cela est
dérisoire des fortunes dépensées pour
réimplanter un insecte des années de
labeur pour chasser les plantes venues
d'ailleurs la nature au dessus de
l'homme où il certains le pensent rond
comme quoi à chacun son idée du paradis
oh
ils sont déjà
q certains vont même parfois plus loin
que le naturaliste
je pense que la terre est faite pour
tous les animaux et des plantes
nous sommes juste une toute petite
partie de cela elle doit s'en souvenir
et arrêter de traiter la terre comme
notre terrain de jeu point de 300
après presque d'être là par
on pourrait penser que tout cela est
dérisoire des fortunes dépensées pour
réimplanter un insecte des années de
labeur pour chasser les plantes venues
d'ailleurs la nature au dessus de
l'homme oui on pourrait le penser
comme quoi à chacun son idée du paradis